oh my gosh ladies
what
a night you crushed it you were
captivating
i i feel like you're reinventing
the show with your dances how does it
feel for you two thank you it still
feels so like even though it's so like
world changing and history making and
never been done before to me it's like
if i'm using my big sister like it's
like it feels so normal and real and i
think that that's
the only way that i would want it to be
you know i think that if things were
weird it would just be weird and then it
wouldn't
translate and then the world would think
it's weird i think the reason why the
world is so comfortable with it is we're
so comfortable with it totally it's so
exciting too to watch the judges i mean
jenna you know these judges but to i
feel like they're excited watching the
new things you are doing by having two
female dancers
yeah i thought it was gonna be so
different than that i was gonna be like
oh gosh i'm not gonna you know like i'm
not gonna have a guy partner i'm gonna
be limited but like just said i and i
feel like and like the judges are saying
it is so fun to see a different twist on
ballroom and just on the show
you know it changes it up it's different
i think it's something to look forward
to um and something to be surprised by
this week we were in a three-inch latin
hill
two girls trying to balance on each
other let me tell you my body
and
and i think with you more is more right
but i think sometimes especially the
side by side
more isn't more you've got to contain
that energy a little bit can get a
little bit wild and lose the quality of
movement and i know that because you're
a dancer hey
jojo you did get a critique tonight from
one derek huff yes sometimes too much
energy
you know that
for me i do really well with things that
i've been told before in my life i do
really well with them and that is
something that i've been told a lot in
my life
um actually i didn't tell you about this
yet but there was a moment on commercial
break right before we went to
elimination and derek looked at me and
was like
um like he like had like a moment he was
like
basically saying like i don't want you
to think that what i said means you did
bad because he knows that that's how
like yeah my brain will automatically
work and it was like
genuine like you did good and
but yeah i think he you know he is right
in a sense of like and we do work on
that and all of our rehearsals is
controlling that energy or just putting
it into intentional places so i'm
excited um for next week because i feel
like we can really take those critiques
and work on them i mean britney week
what song do we have
hit me baby one more time
jojo as someone who also experienced
fame at such a young age what do you
think of when you think of britney
spears especially because she's going
through a lot right now
brittany is
a legend
what britney has done and changed the
world in and
every single thing about her is
legendary you know i think that
i actually was lucky enough to see her
perform in vegas and after watching that
show i was just like that is a performer
that's a genuine true performer and
that's something that i love and is so i
think it's so respectable about her got
a nice little helicopter turning our
party right now yeah has something to
say about mrs spears
i want to be best friends with buddy i
think it'd be so cool
[Music]